investigators searching through a mass
grave in Ukraine safe they've found
evidence that some of the Dead were
tortured the site near isium recently
liberated from Russian forces appears to
be one of the largest discovered in
Ukraine yet but Ukrainian authorities
wanted their investigation was just
beginning
digging up evidence of possible Russian
atrocities lined with body bags this
Pine Forest on the outskirts of isium is
the site of a recent Mass grave
hauling body after body workers here
have already exhumed the remains of 40
people police believe that over 400 may
be buried here some soldiers but also
civilians
forensic inspectors say some of the
bodies bear the marks of torture
we exhumed the first grave and found a
body the Rope was found on the neck of
the body and there are injuries on its
limbs these are all indications of
torture
this old cemetery is now filled with new
crosses some bear the names of the Dead
most are just numbered police say
gravediggers recorded the details of
those they knew
satellite imagery shows the changes in
the landscape from March to August
appearing to show new patches in the
forest the United Nations is preparing
to send an inspection team something
welcomed by Ukraine's president
today the world must see what the
Russian army left behind
another Mass burial of murdered people
children and adults
civilians and Military tortured shot
killed by shelling
in the city of isium emergency services
are still clearing Rubble to search for
bodies believed to be trapped underneath
using documentation Ukraine is hoping to
make the case for illegal recognition of
alleged Russian war crimes
DW correspondent Emmanuel Shaz is in
kharkif not far from isium and Emma I
believe you're actually right now in an
air bunker because there are Air Raid
Sirens out there
um so quite a a again tight situation an
investigators in that region they are
faced with with a gruesome task do tell
us how are they dealing with it
well uh you know Monica even if most of
the region of hardkiv has been liberated
the fact that here we had to take
shelter because of air red alerts which
happened happens day in day out here in
harkive tells you uh just how volatile
the situation is in the region and of
course the task ahead for people who are
uncovering the crimes that took place
during Russian occupation is absolutely
gruesome very difficult imagine that the
investigators have to check over 400
terms 400 Graves where they found
corpses varying traces of torture some
of those Graves also indicate that
people died of hunger last spring while
their cities were occupied there's also
Graves of children there so this will be
a very hard task there's a thousand
police officers from all over the
country who came here in the region to
assist those investigations and there's
already 200 investigations opened by the
general prosecutor to look into those
alleged crimes in the harkif region and
of course this is also a huge trauma for
those who survived the occupation there
how are ukrainians in this newly
liberated area adjusting six months into
this occupation
well yesterday I could visit the region
of hurricane which had been recently
liberated I you know even on the road
you could see the extent of the
destruction there's barely any houses
left untouched even when they only so to
speak have Windows broken most of them
are not inhabitable anymore schools have
been destroyed as well and in balaclia
could talk to some people who told me
their lost relatives who told me some
friends have disappeared and the people
I saw in balaclia they had to queue to
get water to get food from humanitarian
convoys that's the situation they're in
and on top of that they fear that they
now also live with some people who
accommodated themselves under Russian Wu
so you have a very very strange
atmosphere and this will take months if
not years to be fixed right and Emmanuel
obviously this is uh this all coincides
with Ukraine actually making huge gains
other people where you are are they
hopeful that perhaps this this nightmare
could come to an end soon
not really Monica here in Harkey if you
know we're only 35 kilometers away from
the Russian border and I was you know
something that struck me two days ago I
was talking to someone here in harkev
and he was telling me you know as long
as there won't be a gray zone between
the two countries we will always hearing
hark if be under threat of being bombed
by a missile or being under threat of a
new Invasion so people are relieved for
now but most of the people I talk to are
still very fearful that this could all
begin again here all right Emmanuel's
reporting for us from kharkif thank you
so much Emmanuel take care